Aquí tengo un número escrito, tiene un 2, un
3 y un 5, y ya tenemos algo de experiencia con
números así. Pensemos en lo que representa, y para
pensar en esto tenemos que ubicar los valores por
posición. El lugar más a la derecha representa las
unidades, así que este 5 representa 5 unidades;
este 3 está en el lugar de las decenas,
tenemos 3 decenas, por lo que va a ser 30;
y este 2 está en el lugar de las centenas, este
2 aquí significa que tenemos 200. Este número
podemos verlo como 200, 30 y 5 o como 200 +
30 + 5. Lo que quiero hacer en este video es
ver los valores posicionales a la derecha del
lugar de las unidades, y me pueden decir "Oye,
espera. Yo pensé que las unidades estaban en
el lugar más hacia la derecha", y en efecto,
todo lo que hemos hecho hasta este momento ha
sido así, pero para mostrar que podemos ir más
hacia la derecha voy a poner un punto aquí. Y
a esto lo llamamos punto decimal y este punto
significa que todo lo que se encuentre a la
derecha de éste serán valores posicionales
más pequeños que la unidad; si nos vamos a la
izquierda de este punto tenemos las unidades,
las decenas, las centenas, y si seguimos este
era el lugar de los millares. Pero si nos vamos
a la derecha del punto decimal, vamos a dividir
entre 10 cada vez, ¿a qué me refiero? Bueno,
justo a la derecha del punto decimal vamos a
tener el lugar de las décimas. ¿Qué significa
esto? Pues cualquier número que escriba yo
aquí nos va a decir cuántas décimas tenemos
aquí. Si yo escribiera el número 4, mi número
ahora sería 200 + 30 + 5, más 5 unidades más 4
décimas. Lo podemos representar como 4 x 1 / 10,
o podemos escribir 4/10, no decenas, décimas,
o 4 décimas es lo mismo que esto: 4 / 10.
Esta es una idea importante en matemáticas.
Ahora puedo usar mis valores posicionales
para representar fracciones. Este 0.4 son
4 décimas. Otra forma de escribir este número es
235 y 4/10, así que lo puedo escribir así, como un
número mixto. Esto de aquí es una representación
decimal: 235.4, y esta es una representación
usando números mixtos 235 4/10, pero ambos son
200 + 30 + 5 + 4/10. Veamos algunos ejemplos más
de esto. Digamos que quiero analizar el número
0.7 y quiero llegar un lugar más a la derecha.
0.76. ¿Qué representa esto si lo escribiera como
fracción? Analicemos los valores posicionales.
Tenemos nuestro punto decimal, a la izquierda
de este punto está el lugar de las unidades,
pero aquí tengo un cero, 0 unidades; ahora tengo
7 décimas, este es el lugar de las décimas,
y este lugar a la derecha de este, vamos a dividir
entre 10 nuevamente, así que será el lugar de las
centésimas, el lugar de las centésimas. Así que
este lo podemos escribir como 0 unidades más 7
décimas, nuevamente no son decenas son décimas,
más 6 centésimas -seis centésimas, no centenas,
centésimas-, o podemos escribir esto como 0 +
7 décimas más 6 centésimas, 6/100. Este 0 + 7
décimas más 6 centésimas es lo mismo que éste
0.76, podemos llamar a este número 0 unidades,
7 décimas, 6 centésimas. Otra forma es escribir
esto como una sola fracción. Aquí puedo ignorar
este 0, no me va a modificar el valor, y hago la
suma de estas dos fracciones. ¿Cómo puedo escribir
7 décimos en términos de centésimos? Bueno 7 /
10 es lo mismo que 70 / 100. Una forma de verlo
es que si multiplico el denominador por 10 y el
numerador también por 10 no cambio el valor aquí,
voy a tener 70 / 100, y ahora sí puedo sumar
estas 70 centésimas con estas 6 centésimas.
¿Qué es lo que nos va a dar? Pues va a ser 76 /
100. Así que este número de aquí muchas personas
lo llamarán 0.76 o también lo pueden llamar
76/100, este es el lugar de las centésimas,
este es el lugar de las décimas. Pero cada
décima vale 10 centésimas, y esto lo podemos
ver como 7 décimas o como 70 centésimas, así que
son 76 centésimas. Y podemos continuar más hacia
la derecha, si fuéramos un lugar más a la derecha
tendríamos el lugar de las milésimas y otro más a
la derecha sería el lugar de las diezmilésimas,
cada vez que nos movemos a la derecha dividimos
entre 10 cada vez y multiplicamos por 10
cada vez que nos movemos hacia la izquierda.